we've seen you in maybe in the trailer
for a certain star wars thing uh you
can't tell us anything i know but how
excited should fans be for this because
it went a long time to see you and and
hayden back in these roles and back on
back on the big screen yeah i mean
if if it's possible to be any more
excited than folks already are i i would
be i i think it's one of the most uh
thrilling additions to the star wars
canon i think like
doing things with that i cannot tell
[ __ ]
you know
i love how polite he is and what a
murderer he played on uh
homeland
wonderful cameos what an activist i hear
cameos cameo does rupert friend know
some cameos that we don't know about
somebody
are you on the show hey mace window all
across the world you got one arm left
ducky
my cameo is just uh voices just fred
schneider improv
hey mace windu what are you doing save
and grow goo cause no one else will
that's that's going to be a new improv
warm-up
i'm switching it over to mace windu for
sure everyone who tunes into these shows
waiting for like star wars uh
information they're gonna be like why do
tommy and eric keep forcing in their
culty improv background into every one
of these episodes we'll never stop it
it's an itch it's an itch it's nice we
cannot help it
i want to thank um hey you guys for that
rupert friend interview clip hey you
guys are rupert friends to us all we
appreciate you asking the right
questions welcome back to new rockstars
the grand inquisitive will be the most
immediate threat to obi-wan kenobi until
he meets darth vader but actor ripper
friend it's not promising cameos from
people i obviously can't tell you
so what other star wars cameos will this
character share the screen with cause
that
limits our options there doesn't it
and what will they look like on
i decided to mix it up this week i made
a choice it was a cute kenobi
i'm still on the fence about it it was a
nice easter sweet easter bunny choice
it was yeah easter easter eggs galore
here monday morning after the the
hard-boiled eggs are unfound and rotting
around uh
casa de vasa yeah and they will this is
just the home smell now when you walk in
it's uh it's like the dad saying i can
see a couple easter eggs from where i
stand and you haven't found yet
but it's two weeks later it's two weeks
later and that and then you grow up and
you become a person who finds these
drinks
yes my curse but awesome oh we just got
an origin story
i mean they have to do a breakdown on
eric voss's or eric voss just admitted
on an episode of wikileaks that as a
child he couldn't find all his easter
eggs leading to an obsession as an adult
i think i need to be like uh the joker
and i have alternate stories for how i
got it and you you did make up your mind
you want to know why i find these eggs
my father
was a hider
and every year
he'd get real drunk
and hide easter eggs all over the lawn
and at the point i'm gonna say this
story to somebody and i'm like you wanna
know why i find these eggs and they say
no but i know how you found these and
just throw eggs at me as i'm walking
down to visit arrow maybe me at that
point i'll be a a hobo
street performer that just juggles
rotten eggs they call me rotten tommy
and you'll be like that'll be my origin
story they already do call me rotten
tommy
that's your amateur wrestling ring name
like rotten tommy you eat rotten food
there comes rotten tommy my god that's
rotten tommy smell from the top rope
it's rotten tommy eggs everywhere eggs
everywhere
[Laughter]
already off the rails
but this is how i prefer to be off the
rails the rails do not exist when i'm
talking with tommy screw the rails well
by the way this is wikileaks it's our
star wars show we're goofing around
because you know there's we're in the
the fun period of star wars speculation
we don't have new immediate footage to
break down but we're here with you every
week because we know you star wars
junkies need a bit of tom and eric to
get you through your mondays that's
right so here's here's what we're doing
this episode tommy and i are gonna run
down the list of every possible juicy
cameo that might appear in this obi-wan
kenobi series based on rupert friend
grand inquisitor saying that he knows of
some cameos because i think it's
interesting that he says this because
you gotta imagine when we're speculating
on cameos for this show if it's just
like a force ghost on tatooine rupert
friend wouldn't know about that you know
he only knows the people who he had
scenes with he doesn't know what the big
picture is going to be so we're talking
cameos that would be in the scene with
the grand inquisitor which gives us some
interesting uh options that i don't
think we've really discussed yet so
we're going to talk about them in this
episode but before we get into that time
is running out to grab yourself the moon
knight latest obsession shirt from new
rockstars merch it's called tomb of the
moon god i'm wearing it right now buying
it not only directly supports us here at
new rockstars but it also unlocks the
ability to get a shout out in our weekly
inside marvel show so get this before it
sells out over at newrockstarsmerch.com
it's a great shirt it's got secrets in
it it's got secrets that you know you
gotta you gotta see if you can decode
it's all down there too see that see
that am i showing a bit of midriff here
all right
little flirty monday again
to your heart
moist monday over here at uh wikileaks
uh but tommy what's our first question
oh man what surprise cameos will appear
in kenobi with the grand inquisitor
with the grand inquisitor so imagine so
beyonce let's say it's episode four
episode five we've already seen our
darth vader we've already gotten some
other teases to the felony verse but now
we uh we're in a scene with the grand
inquisitor on the fortress inquisitorius
uh maybe the death star uh who would
appear in this uh this imperial turf
with the sky or who or who might this
guy be hunting down who might be
interesting uh so let's go through the
options of who we know is already in the
show so obviously obi-wan kenobi darth
vader owen lars baru lars grand
inquisitors in the show and then we're
gonna meet the third sister moses
ingram's character uh sun kang uh uh uh
justice for han he's only the fifth
brother he's gonna be in the show uh
indira varma playing some imperial
officer uh we also know for sure that
luke skywalker age ten can be played by
grand philly and then uh and then the
rest of the cast we got camille
non-gianni o'shea jackson jr simone
kessel benny safty maya erskine from
pim15 and then rory ross we don't know
what roles they're playing i imagine
they're gonna be something like uh you
know like bill burr's character in the
mandalorian someone who just starts off
as a one one-off character but they
might come back in some other fun ways
yeah so let's run through the speculated
options uh one of the biggest cameos
people want to see in the show
is samuel l jackson as mace windu um
we just want some acknowledgement that
he
actually did survive
his fall from the chancellor's quarters
um
if mace windu shows up at the show i
think very likely i just don't know if
uh if rupert friend would know about
that right um because unless he was the
one who eventually tracked down and
killed mace windu um because mace windu
as far as we know i don't think he would
have lived through the uh lived through
the galactic civil wars in the events of
the original trilogy i feel like if mace
windu was alive for that he would have
shown up somewhere you know unless he
was completely in exile i just think if
mace windu ever shows up it's just gonna
be some acknowledgement that he survived
that night and then had some other
adventure maybe being the the person who
got grogu to safety or helping out in
some other way but i think he
i feel like he would have met his end uh
at some point in the past i just don't
know if we're gonna see the the
mandalorian era of uh of star wars with
mace old man mace windu running around i
would love to see that i just don't know
the only scenario with mace that i could
see that would satisfy him still being
alive is if that
kind of attack by anakin or the newly
minted darth vader just broke him
psychologically and he was just like a
crave like the way that luke thought
yoda was crazy like if if mace windu
actually was that crazy it was exiled
and maybe being protected by other
jedi's but essentially
like maybe
kind of almost like the mr glass
character in the uh in the in the uh you
know in those trilogies where he like
makes a lot of sense up to like 30 or 40
or 50 percent of what he's saying and
then the last 50 is just bat [ __ ] insane
so i would i would not prefer that i
want my mace window to be heroic but the
only way i could see them keeping that
character alive as you said without
having him you know
have participated is if he's just so
psychologically damaged from the insane
betrayal that occurred right in front of
him and to him yeah i'm just thinking
like if uh if mace windu was alive
during the during the original trilogy
of events of a new hope empire and then
jedi like we
things would not have been so bleak for
the jedi at that point if if he survived
that i think yoda would know i think
obi-wan probably would have been able to
figure it out that his old you know
friend on the jedi council is still
alive somewhere so i just think like he
i think he did survive that night i
think it'd be great for lucasfilm to
just say that mace windu was able to use
his one good hand to grab one of those
coruscant cars and then and then get to
the jedi temple and help out somebody or
do something um and now that would just
require a lot of de-aging tech on on
samuel l jackson but they've done it
before
disney has the technology they can do it
again they got the templates just slap
those templates down come on just drag
and drop the the
captain marvel stuff right on him yeah
you'll be good to go through all the
effects people being like that's not how
easy it is and i i know it's not that
easy i know that i'm just being a jerk
that's what i do we're just being jerks
okay let's talk about the organa family
so jimmy smits we think is going to show
up in cassie and andorra makes a lot of
sense probably the genevieve o'reilly is
mon mothma i just remember that one
scene from rogue one i want to see those
two you know play both sides the
political and the rebel spies um but
there's a lot of speculation that since
we're getting 10 year old luke we could
see 10 year old leia there's some
speculation that vivian lira blair might
be playing leia organa i think she might
show up in obi-wan kenobi i'm just
thinking would the grand inquisitor have
shared a scene with her because if
you're the grand inquisitor and you're
talking to ten-year-old laira organa
that would mean like you suspect her for
having sensitivity that you saw some
jedi or some holocron and
kill her the fact that leia survived
that would make me think that yeah uh
the great inquisitor never met her never
suspected her i don't think so so um
while she might show up in the show i
don't think that's one of the cameo or
maybe he's read all the scripts and he's
like yeah leia's gonna be in this i i
don't know i just think they're uh
likely yeah for some reason they gave
they gave him every single top secret
script they're like we just want some
notes just give us any feedback you have
hit us up on the slack i mean there
could be a scene where he like
he uh you know he's not allowed to move
yet on just for sensitivity uh so like
he has some way of scanning kids or
maybe leia's name shows up in holocron
and then like bail organa is like look
you have made a mistake i'm a powerful
political figure and then maybe uh great
inquisitor is like well your day's
unnumbered senator
one of these days things are gonna shift
so
look after this one make sure no jedi
ever talks to her that'd be a pretty
freaking cool scene on alderaan and then
maybe he looks around and he starts like
running his finger along the walls he's
like
enjoy this place while it lasts
something doesn't sit right here hmm
well wait no no need to leave no need to
leave just camp out right here
i'll be back oh maybe i won't maybe i
won't be back maybe i will be back
[Laughter]
he just takes his lightsaber twirls away
and they're like like mary poppins
wow that guy was cool right
let's talk about uh grogu yes
are we gonna revisit look because here's
the deal here's the i know this is an
obi-wan kenobi show i know it's about a
certain story about a certain character
but look we all we also had a show
called the book of boba fett and for
whatever reason we had a whole episode
without a minute and we flashed back to
the night of order 66 it seems like
every star wars series is at some point
just gonna re-address order 66 could
this be the show that tells us how grogu
got out of the temple uh it could i
don't think it needs to be i think this
show
i think this show should
i love grogu
you've all seen my home there's little
grogues everywhere i uh i wish i could
have a real grogu and raise him as my
foundling but i think that this show
will be able to stand on its own without
any
direct
mandalorian
uh crossover you know i think there are
characters that have appeared on the
mandalorian or the book of boba fett
that could appear on this show but not
grogu you know i don't think it needs to
be grogu i just it's kenobi this show
could be all about kenobi it's it should
be all about kenobi that's what i agree
agreed i mean they could establish that
kenobi was the one who snuck uh grogu
out of that temple like uh but he didn't
get there until the next day it would
have to like it would have to mean that
that night grogu was tucked away
somewhere in like a cabinet or a lazy
susan and then uh and then
kenobi got there the next day after he
talked to
after he talked to yoda watch the
security footage of cinderlake and the
other kids being killed and then
obi-wan's like even the younglings yeah
and then you know yoda pieces out and
then uh obi-wan turns his head like
what's that little cooing sound behind
that chair and then he finds the little
egg thing
but that i don't know if that's the most
dramatic way to reveal grogu's survival
i think it should just be mace clutching
him like a football uh
using his good hand to kill as many
people as he can that's what i want to
see that's what i would like yeah it
should be i agree whether in this show
or some future show maybe if you do a
mace windu series mace windu mini series
that could be how it starts yeah and
then we say goodbye to goku as he pushes
them down a river mm-hmm and then
in the reeves
i tried so hard to watch uh prince of
egypt uh this this past weekend i feel
like that should be my easter slash
passover watching yeah we watch elf
during christmas time we should watch
prince of egypt absolutely underrated
movie under
that movie define my childhood i got
that soundtrack i would just like sit at
home on friday nights and just blare
stephen schwartz's music because mariah
carey and whitney houston sang their
[ __ ] hearts bangers
oh yeah bangers and i would just scream
at my living room when i was 11 years
old i loved that movie so much brenda
chapman
brandon chapman was a uh
animation director yeah from the lion
king good work brother pixar's brave
boys club at pixar just kicked her right
right right right off of that movie get
the hell out super talented super town
the enemy thank you for making prince of
egypt
um
anyway let's talk about some other jedi
who might show up on the show now i
think the theme of the show is that like
the jedi are scattered they are at their
weakest state in all of history um
but there are some rumors that we might
see qui-gon jinn sports ghost maybe yoda
could show up as like a force projection
force ghost at some point uh liam neeson
frank oz still out there still could
show up on the show
i just don't think
uh that the grand inquisitor actor would
know about this no that was because it
was that big of a deal
yeah i don't think he would see the
force ghost i don't think he would yeah
we really don't have a lot of uh
information on yoda uh post uh order 66
right we don't really know what he went
to we know we know some
we know uh his arrival from dagobah from
some of the other associated material um
yeah he was uh and he was involved in
rebels he was uh
we saw him during the rebels timeline
but this would be rebels would be after
this so yeah we don't know exactly where
this is why i love that they picked this
year because it's just right in the
middle of this kind of uh this dark
period where we know some stuff from
like associate material but like none of
the series have really just like focused
on these years in particular
okay a couple other runaway jedi out
there who we have speculated here ahsoka
tano calcastus yes give me calcast this
baby calcastus is my number one here's
my number one draft pick for this this
he's my number one this is who i want
this is who i believe will show up in
the scene with the grand inquisitor this
is this is who i got for sure for sure
uh you know seeing him in jedi fall in
order there's going to be a fallen order
follow-up you know so
depending on when that follow-up happens
uh it kind of determines whether or not
we'd see calcus on the show but i think
of all the star wars announced titles
this is a perfect one and i think this
is an example of we could see you know
the grand inquisitor hunting down calcus
because the inquisitors are aware of
calcus
so he could be a target of theirs and
that could be something that rupert
friend was referring to like maybe he
shared a scene or saw like cameron
monaghan's face on a screen or it was
like scripted out to be a certain way
and he had to say like cal questis
uh escaped uh you know like and he has
he can kind of talk about like the past
of the fortress inquisitorius and when
he was there in the past like i think to
me that seems super likely that's that's
in my uh most likely of the list we're
going through today i think um
now a couple other people that i think
could be interesting to think about um
uh if you think about the grand
inquisitor's origin right it was
revealed that he was a temple guard
um in the trial of ahsoka tano embarrass
in that season five clone wars arc that
one of those temple guards was uh went
on to be the grand inquisitor um so this
sets up a couple interesting options
barris offi we don't know where she was
during the night of order 66 she was
just kind of like in in containment she
was uh being she's in a prison somewhere
in the jedi temple um and then uh but
there's other characters like the
imperial ranking grand moff tarkin could
make an appearance steven stanton's been
doing some great voice work as tarkin
and bad batch and clone wars guy henry
and rogue one did the initial stand-in
before they did the the animated face
recreating peter cushing right guy henry
does a pretty good tarkin impression um
that i think he could do an interesting
standing thing stephen stanton looks the
part too i wouldn't mind if he did it
yeah i would love to see a live-action
younger tarkin yeah you won't we don't
need to do the no the animation on the
face again no need to reactivate them
just have an actor play them yeah just
have an activity i'll leave you on this
uh i i don't think we're gonna see maul
on this show right that's so much has
been said um oh another jedi i forgot to
mention luminara unduli is someone who
uh survived kashyyyk during 66. and then
she died the grand inquisitor captured
her uh so in rebels season one wasn't
season one yeah you find out that like
he used her corpse to lure in kanan and
ezra so like we could see her capture by
the grand inquisitor in her uh
interrogation so i think luminar and
dooley along with cal calcus are two
most likely other jedi uh jedi runaways
that uh the grain inquisitor could cross
paths with um but i think ultimately i
would love to see
and i know there's some mixed feelings
about emperor palpatine
mysterious return somehow and the rise
of skywalker
mcdarmid
ian mcdarmid izzle is awesome yeah i
think this would be a perfect
opportunity i imagine like the grand
inquisitor the boss's boss uh to the
grand inquisitor like him showing up
dropping the hammer uh like i think that
would be a very very exciting cameo that
could totally work on this show so of
this list i want us to rank like what we
think are top three
likeliest cameos that uh rupert friend
was talking about sure tommy what are
your topics i told you my number one
pick is calcus i think he just makes a
lot of sense to be in the show i think
that like his involvement being hunted
down by
by a grand inquisitor makes makes a ton
of sense i also think
i like you you kind of want me over on
the opening
our discussion i like a bell organa
cameo with the grand inquisitor where
like maybe it's a video conference thing
but it's kind of like
maybe it's a maybe it's uh maybe that's
the reference to leo we get on the show
is belle organa kind of running
interference and being like this we have
it all taken care of here you have no
like you have no right to come down here
go away and then grant inquisitor being
like i have my eye on you or whatever
you know like that type exactly how you
laid it out that just seems like a lot
of fun and then i don't know i know we
just
you know it seems like this would just
be annoying to people or or or people
would be like we don't need more of this
but i do think it makes sense that
palpatine eventually shows up again
maybe possibly as a projection or a
video or like you know what i mean you
know
like on a remote i think it makes sense
to have the boss's boss weigh in right
like this is like we're the part of this
show a subplot
of
kenobi is kind of introducing where the
empire is at at this point right like
that's gotta be like that's a whole
that's clearly what we're getting so
we would need to know what the emperor
is up to and ian mcdermott is awesome
and with the heavy it doesn't matter the
palpatine appearance he could be he
could literally do this till he's 105.
you know it's like he could just do a
voice you could do a holocron
exactly so those are my three how about
you eric um i i kind of arranged them
into groups like types of cameos yes so
i at the bottom of my list i'm gonna go
with a wild card uh i didn't mention
them in my list here but um i think
we're gonna see a clone trooper played
by tomorrow morris oh nice yeah i think
that's just a fun opportunity and at
this point as we know from bad batch the
clone troopers are being eradicated
tarkin's like we don't need them anymore
we don't trust using clone troopers
they're compromisable so i think uh it'd
be really fun to see rex
now uh an inquisitor scene with rex
might be um
uh
bad news for rex we know rex survives
this because he shows up in rebels um
but i think uh there is a scene in the
trailer where it looks like he's closing
in on a bald person that just looks like
the back of tomorrow morrison's head so
it's a wild card i'll acknowledge that
but he would be my number three pick my
number two pick is going to be um
some uh authority figures so either
either palpatine or tarkin and it might
just be the voice of them or something
like that someone who like
someone the fact that we see indira
varma playing an imperial officer i
think someone who she has to report to
she's kind of a rival maybe to rupert
friend's character that you have like
the inquisitors who are these former
jedi who have been corrupted to hunt
down other jedis who to who represent
this kind of mystical side project of
darth vader to an otherwise very strict
uh military branch uh of the empire so i
think uh i think someone she reports to
um that being tarkin or or maybe
palpatine so uh of those two i think
palpatine's my more preferred option uh
just museum mcdormand's great i'd love
to see him in anything uh so my number
one pick is going to be some runaway
jedi so of that group uh you know mace
windu cow castes or luminar unduly um i
think of those three in this show calcus
would be the most fun but i think most
likely is gonna be luminara unduly just
because we know from rebels that he that
grant inquisitor illuminar have that
backstory there so i think uh for if you
imagine like a flashback with him where
he's like
capturing her that's something that
rupert friend might have at the top of
his head he's like i know this isn't a
very important jedi to star wars fans um
they're gonna go ape [ __ ] when they see
this yeah uh cause i'm gonna go look at
ours i'm gonna go with luminara
all right tommy and i have some uh more
thoughts that we wanna share and discuss
about uh how exactly the obi-wan kenobi
series is going to tie into lines from a
new hope a specific line from darth
vader that now will have a completely
different meaning as a result of the
obi-wan show before we get to that we
want to thank mint mobile for sponsoring
this episode with big wireless providers
there's always a catch so when i first
heard that mint mobile offers premium
wireless starting at just 15 bucks a
month i thought what's the catch here
but there isn't one that's the catch no
catch mint mobile secret sauce is that
they are the first company to sell
wireless service online only so they cut
out the cost of retail stores and they
pass on those sweet savings directly to
you new rockstar is head of
post-production riley loves his mint
mobile plan he switched over even before
they started sponsoring the show so he's
a true believer he loves that he got to
keep his phone and his number but just
saves so much money every month for
anyone who hates their phone bill mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 bucks a month mobile gives you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or for a family and at mint families
start at two lines so all plants come
with unlimited talk and text plus high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5g network to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and to get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mobile.com wookie that's
mintmobile.com wookie cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mimmable.comwookie we also want to thank
storyworth for sponsoring this episode
have you ever flipped through your mom's
high school yearbook or your grandma's
old photo album and realized there are
just huge portions of their life you
didn't know anything about that happened
to our researcher anna recently and
that's why she got her mom story work
story worth is an online service that
helps you and your loved ones connect
through sharing stories and memories and
preserves them for years to come every
week story worth emails your mom or
whoever you get this for a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from a vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt to ask
questions you've never thought of like
what's some of the best advice your
mother gave you or if you were to do it
all over what would you do differently
it's just a really cool process for your
mom or your grandmother to reflect back
on their life and share their stories
and it's just really cool for you and
your family to learn more about them
that way after one year story worth
compiles all these questions and stories
including photos into a beautiful
keepsake book for the whole family that
they can share for generations just have
on the coffee table people flip through
it and you can tell them the story about
how you and your mom did this for a year
it's a cool gift so give all the moms in
your life a meaningful gift that you'll
both cherish for years story worth right
now for a limited time you'll save ten
dollars on your first purchase when you
go to storyworth.com wookie that's
s-t-o-r-y-w-o-r-t-h
dot com slash wookie with two e's to
save ten dollars on your first purchase
storyworth.comwookie and we want to
thank coinbase for sponsoring this
episode if you've ever been following
the cryptocurrency craze now is the time
to start getting involved coinbase makes
it easy and quick to start your own
portfolio and to learn to trade like a
pro coinbase offers a trusted and easy
to use platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone
they offer portfolio management
protection learning resources and a
mobile app mobile app mobile app so you
can trade securely and monitor your
crypto all in one place millions of
people in over 100 countries trust
coinbase with their digital assets
whether you're looking to diversify just
getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase and for a
limited time new users can get ten
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
today at coinbase.com wookie sign up at
coinbase.com wookie for ten dollars in
free bitcoin this is an offer for a
limited time only so be sure to sign up
today that's coinbase.com wookie all
right tommy let's remind ourselves of
the epic line in darth vader in obi-wan
kenobi's duel on the death star in star
wars new hope 1977. he says i've been
waiting for you obi-wan we meet at last
the circle is now complete when i left
you i was but a learner but now i am the
master yeah then obviously only a master
of evil darth and i like how he calls
him darth in that moment like george
lucas clearly did not imagine that as a
title he imagined that as his first name
uh so it's just one of these little
things from the first star wars it's
like please never change that it's just
such a great way to talk to him uh i'm
getting a bunch of star wars uh fans
right now screaming at me like that's a
completely reasonable thing to for a
jedi to call a sith i just like it i'm
not criticizing anything i think it's
fun i love it it's okay to like now it's
also okay to dislike we're not going to
judge what your opinions are whatever
but tommy
i will i wanted to ask you now that
we're looking at obi-wan kenobi we know
that he and darth vader are going to
have a rematch in this series what do
you think darth vader meant by when i
left you i was but a learner now i am
the master i think this was a huge
miscommunication between two old friends
that had had a lot of conflict i think
what darth vader was trying to tell
obi-wan is that he finally finished his
master's degree
and now
he has a post-grad
and he's saying like when i left you i
was floundering through my undergrad you
know i wasn't even sure what i wanted to
major in because here i was saying i was
majoring in jedi over there having a
baby two of them as a matter of fact
with natalie portman i didn't know what
i wanted to be maybe i wanted to be a
daddy but now i'm a master a sith master
and i think it was meant to entice a a
cash gift a graduation present but
unfortunately those are well if you go
through and read lucas's early drafts
there's a lot of undergrad and post-grad
subplots
he clearly had an agenda against the
american college system and and student
loans uh
yeah oh for sure well you know i think i
think that um
i think that we can interpret this two
ways i'm choosing to interpret the
literal way which is that what he means
when he's saying i left you it doesn't
mean the last time he saw him he means
it is when i left you and was no longer
your apprentice or was no longer
learning from you
i still was not a complete
whatever sith or at that point jedi i
was incomplete but now
i am at the top of my game i am the
master i am the sith master there is no
one better at this than me i
i am superior to you now
my training is complete i think that's
what he means i think it's just it can
be literally interpreted how about you
um i think it's a completely valid way
to interpret it i choose the
metaphorical path
um but
but
the way i see this is there are now
three implicit questions with this
question uh when i left you so when did
he really leave him no uh i was but a
learner so what does it mean what did he
mean by but a learner and when he says
now i am the master so what happened
since that other fight to make darth
vader a master how did he recover from
that and what other experiences did he
go through on his own after this rematch
with obi-wan kenobi to make him now a
master was it just he killed enough of
those rebel soldiers on the way to the
tan to four he's like oh oh that's my
fifth one in a row i got a streak i'm a
master now
i so i think addressing those questions
one by one i think now uh after revenge
of the sith many of us assumed oh when i
left you
but revenge of the sith it was obi-wan
who left him so i think that tells us
about this rematch duel it's going to be
vader who walks away from it and it's
obi-wan who's left limping um so i think
vader's gonna come out on top there but
he still considered himself a learner
there so i think the nature of that
fight is going to be a a relationship
between teacher and pupil i think
obi-wan is still going to be schooling
him in that fight it says
look look at your feet placing right now
look at your feet
what have i told you about your
breathing you can't even breathe right
now you need to machine it you're
breathing like imagine obi-wan does
tanti and his student
just being such an [ __ ] to him like i
i think like uh
the arc for vader is to still learn how
to like work through this weird new body
that he has
and that's going to be the learning
process and still learn how to use the
force to empower every new component of
him and then lastly now i am the master
i think the threat there is that
uh like
look
technically in this sith duo
relationship that he has with palpatine
if he said that in front of palpatine
palpatine would be super threatened
because palpatine is the master like for
an apprentice is to say now he is the
master even when he's using it to taunt
her taunt his former master
that would be something that
would be like
wait
the the pop calling from the bleachers
like hey hey hey who taught you how to
swing the bet huh who taught you you're
all man dead i can drink in public shut
up yeah
i could have been i could have had a
yankee
i could have had a yankee
i can't i don't know
no but i think that what it is is it's a
threat to obi-wan in that moment like
not only am i more powerful than you old
man i'm willing to call myself a master
even though i have the scariest master
in the world who could be listening in
on this conversation right now so i
think the implication of it is that
i am no longer really that afraid of
palpatine so that's why you need to be
afraid of me is i think i think i can
take him i think i can take palpatine
and indeed he later does well it isn't
that
isn't that very long the thought process
of anakin skywalker that's a much more
anakin thought than a vader thought of
like yeah i'm better than this guy like
anakin's whole life he was like i could
do this way ahead of when he should have
been able to do it so i like it well i
hope that line gets referenced in some
way i assume it will be you got to
imagine
the team at lucasfilm made an entire
movie out of like uh like one sentence
in brian de palma's opening uh scroll
from a new hope if they could do that
they're gonna they're gonna make a meal
out of this awesome line from a new hope
in in this show so i can't wait to see
it come up tommy and i are gonna lose
their minds when that comes up uh but
that is it for this week's episode of
wikileaks again don't forget to check
out our integrated merch options over at
newrocksmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow tommy tommybeck told follow new
rockstars and uh subscribe to wikileaks
wherever we get your podcasts thanks for
watching we'll see you next week goodbye
you